it sounds like your battles of sever
immortality with Goro is near a
conclusion you killed all those who
interfered I did they see you did well
to kill without hesitation
don't forget Sakura is it 8 and you lose
that is the way of war when he was young
oisin fought desperately spending his
days in pursuit of life-or-death combat
and from each enemy he conquered he took
something of their style polishing his
arts in the blood of his enemies
ichimonji the recognition that posture
is a samurais most treasured trait a
sheen across an art devoted to the swift
an indulgent kill and perhaps most
importantly there was one mind which
requires the user to focus their entire
soul on the release of their blade
because for all of his ruminations on
swordplay Ishi UNS blade always moved
first he stopped at nothing in his
search for strength and the
single-minded focus ended with him
taking back a sheena for his own it
attracted a ton of people to his cause
even prominent bandits like yo boo Oni
wha-hoo when he was defeated by eachine
actually accepted the offer to serve in
his army and when they crushed the
Tamara clan and cemented the Ashna
within the land
ition remembered those who fought by his
side he gave gyobu the spear of the
general he had defeated and he also made
him retainer to the young lord ganesha'
row Ian's adopted grandson who would
eventually lead the hashanah in the
years to come good at you
[Music]
later in life the elderly issue was more
akin to a sharpened blade his steadily
honed techniques had culminated in the
ashiness style soundly eliminating all
wasted or idle movement the ways of the
archana blade it's our school of fading
but there are no hard and fast rules you
just win your battles that alone is the
most important roar of the Hasina style
with a clan that Revere's him and many
who follow in his footsteps he is a
master who took the spirit of his craft
to its pinnacle a true sword Saint yet
all things come to an end and with each
in aging and ailing the interior
ministry finally saw their chance to
move against the ocean once more we
managed to drive them back once but the
Interior Ministry's Army is far too
powerful look at this mountain of bodies
our sheena cannot be defended by normal
means not anymore
Ganesha Dora Sheena now faces the
overwhelming forces of the Interior
Ministry this faction that's poised to
reunite all of Japan it's an enormous
responsibility given the end of days
that the aschen are now faced and it's
this pressure that moves him to kidnap
the divine heir and leave his shinobi
dead in a ditch and that is why you wish
to use the power of my blood it doesn't
matter how much power you obtain you'll
keep on fighting until you're a monster
incapable of feeling pain or fear I do
not wish to corrupt the lives of men
curiously
Genichiro is not grandson tuition by
blood instead he was adopted born a
peasant and taken in by the a sheena
after his mother's death
this land is everything to me for her
sake humanity itself the way he refers
to the land it's almost as if it took on
his mother's role after her death as a
result he would turn to all manner of
heretic alots
in order to better fight on her behalf
it's likely for this reason that he
learned the Lightning of Toma way what
exactly is the Lightning of tomboy that
it's a technique belonging to Ganesha
Rosemont oh I'll wager it was quite the
site his mentor Doughboy Tim away was of
the Okami a warrior from a divine realm
who descended to the lands of the
Oceania earned many masters of the sword
like to see her fight
it's like she's dancing when you look
into her eyes
you feel as if you're being drawn into
the depths of the ocean I was completely
taken by her and it almost killed me I
have lived a long life but that was the
closest I've come to death she was here
to sever the immortality of another
divine heir like Kudo and while she was
here she made this really notable visit
to semper temple in search of their red
mortal blade the red mortal blade it is
said can bestow the gracious gift of
Tears which is the first step in
severing immortality however it seems
she never found it and perhaps resorted
to a cruder black blade instead a blade
named open gate that can also bring the
dead back to life a blade that may be
not so surprisingly ended up in Ganesha
toes hands many years later
Genichiro once faced you without fear
even though you are undying just hoping
to wear down your resolve and win you to
his side with sheer strength however
when that fails it's these mortal blades
that Ganesha ro eventually feels he must
resort to in order to kill you
in order to extract the dragon's blood
from kudo the Crimson mortal blade that
means the one that he has must be black
then to abandon oneself in search of
strength how tragic
meanwhile oisin is fighting a war of his
own sickness is taking its toll and the
interior ministry have their ear pressed
to his door just listening for the first
sign of weakness that could indicate the
right time to strike so he disguises
himself as the Tengu freeing himself
from his identity
leaving him able to hunt down the rats
that are infiltrating his home who are
hmm ministry rats they find a way in
through every crack and crevice there's
always more of them to kill but this
approach cannot last long Lord if she
I'm concerned that the Tengu will make
another appearance Emma yes imagine
Ganesha doe will show up eventually to
put it to use the other mortal blade to
protect a Sheena he'll abandon
everything about who he is Marty yes I
expect no less from my own grandchild
when itching draws his sword he focuses
on his own soul on the self yet when
gain Ichiro draws his he draws it for
his country his motivations are rooted
in his childhood trauma of peasantry
losing his mother and then being saved
by what he sees as the country of
Oceania it's admirable to an extent but
his nationalism ends up being his fatal
flaw and it costs him everything for a
country is made up of its people and the
man at its head sacrifices his humanity
to keep it alive ironically if he had
not then you and kuru may have fought on
the a Sheena's behalf instead of against
it by antagonizing you and
he brings death to go boo defender of
the castle gates and hundreds of our
Sheena's own soldiers he neglects his
duties by going all in on a search for
immortality when it was his country that
needed him most in the end
Genichiro is forced to accept that
Archana is already dead and the only
thing that's possible now is to bring it
back to life in the end I was powerless
[Music]
grandfather wasn't a Sheena will rise
once more with a dragon blood searching
through her veins with this ocean as
long night comes to an end
[Music]
pitiful grandchild this was your last
wish to see her she now returned from
the great beyond
[Music]
which means Sakura
I must destroy one who returns from the
great beyond does so at the peak of
their prosperity a sheen coveted
strength and all manner of techniques
throughout his mortal struggle
hesitation his defeat I told you there
didn't I he wished for war until his
final power do it better stays and that
is precisely what he got
take my head well done sir Kudo farewell
before I end this video I want to show
off the Sennheiser PC 37 X is this
really good budget headset that's
currently $30 off if you use the link in
the description and it's a product that
was already recommending to friends even
before drop reached out to me I used to
use drop calm way back when it was still
called mass drop and I always liked
their collaborations with big brands
because they tend to clean up their
designs and also offer a cheaper price
on top of that this clean matte black
headset is no exception
so first up it has an open back design
which I personally prefer and use over
closed back headphones open-back
headphones prevent heat buildup they
afford a more natural sort of sound
which is great for editing and you can
actually hear sounds that are around you
while you're gaming or listening to
music since I've been playing Demon
Souls all week there were moments in
game in latria in particular where
having good surround sound just saved my
life being able to attract enemies
behind me and also if you want to adjust
that volume the headphones also come
with a volume slider on the right ear
cup which is something you'll come to
swear by once you've gotten used to it
one thing that does usually bother me
with headsets is that they often skimp
out on the microphone quality because
usually if you think about it it's your
friends hearing the Micra
phone not the user so manufacturers
often let it slide however one of the
best selling points of these headphones
is that the mic quality is way better
than its competitors at this price point
which as you can hear now has lots of
body and a detail to it that is only
enhanced by the inbuilt noise cancelling
the PC 37 X punches way above its weight
for the price point so check it out in
the description below if you're in the
market for this kind of thing thank you
to drop for sponsoring me and letting me
try my hand at being a techy youtuber
it was actually a lot of fun filming
something completely different like this
so I appreciate the opportunity thank
you for watching and we'll see you next
time
you